>> Greg: HI, GREG GUTFELD WITH
JEDEDIAH BILA, JESSE WATTERS,
JUAN WILLIAMS, DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
WE ARE NOW INTO THE FOURTH YEAR
OF THE DEMOCRATS ELECTION
TANTRUM.
THAT WOULD BE OLD ENOUGH FOR
KINDERGARTEN BUT MATURITY
MATTERS MORE THAN YEARS SO
THEY'LL NUMBER GET IN.
THEY HAVE LEARNED FROM THE BEST,
THE MEDIA.
>> I HAVE SAT ON HIS ANSWER IS
GOBBLEDYGOOK.
THE FACT THAT MUELLER WROTE A
LETTER OF PROTEST.
>> IN WILLIAM BARR, WE HAVE A
STAUNCH TRUMP ALLY WHO IS ALSO A
SKILLED BUREAUCRAT AND HE IS
SMARTER THAN DONALD TRUMP.
THAT MAKES HIM SCARIER ON BOTH
MEASURES.
>> IF YOUR THEORY ON BARR IS
CORRECT, WHERE DID HE BECOME
RADICALIZED?
>> IF WE CAN'T TRUST YOU ALL TO
TELL US, THEN I FEEL LIKE THERE
IS A COUP HAPPENING.
>> GAS LIGHTING.
>> Greg: GAS LIGHTING.
NOT EXACTLY RATIONAL ANALYSIS
BUT GOING TO "THE VIEW" FOR
INSIGHT IS LIKE GOING TO THE ZOO
FOR AN OIL CHANGE OR HILLARY FOR
LEGAL EXPERTISE.
>> HE IS THE PRESIDENT'S DEFENSE
LAWYER.
HE IS NOT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THE WAY
THAT HE HAS CONDUCTED HIMSELF.
CALLING FOR HIS REGULATION     R
CALLING FOR HIS REGULATION     S
CALLING FOR HIS REGULATION     G
CALLING FOR HIS REGULATION     A
CALLING FOR HIS REGULATION     I
CALLING FOR HIS REGULATION     N
MAKES PERFECT SENSE BECAUSE HE'S
NOT DISCHARGING THE DUTIES OF
THE OFFICE.
>> Greg: GETTING ADVICE FROM
HILLARY IS LIKE GETTING DRIVING
TIPS FROM BETO OR FACTS FROM
THESE SHOWBOATING HACKS.
>> HE TESTIFIED FALSELY
DELIBERATELY.
>> HIS CREDIBILITY WAS SHREDDED
YESTERDAY.
>> I THINK HE SHOULD RESIGN.
>> BURN THROUGH ANY CREDIBILITY
HE HAD IN THAT ROLE AND HE
SHOULD RESIGN.
>> Greg: IT IS LIKE THEY ALL
TOOK THE SAME DRUG.
UNLESS YOU CAN CLAIM THEM AS
DEPENDENTS, YOU DON'T NEED THESE
PEOPLE.
THEY LIE TO YOUR FACE AND TELL
YOU WHAT'S IN THE REPORT ISN'T
REALLY THERE, BUT IT IS.
IN CASE YOU'VE FORGOTTEN THE
MEDIA IS HOPING YOU DID, THE
REPORT IS PUBLIC.
SORRY, GUYS, IT'S ALL IN THERE.
IF THERE WERE ANY CRIMES, WE
WOULD KNOW.
GUESS WHAT.
WE DO.
>> THE EVIDENCE IS NOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS FALSELY ACCUSED OF
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS AND
WE CONCLUDED THAT THE EVIDENCE
DEVELOPED DURING THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION WAS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO ESTABLISH THAT THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE OFFENSE.
>> Greg: ONE WONDERS WHAT KIND
OF BOZOS RELITIGATE WHAT'S OVER
AND DONE WITH?
>> HE IS ACTUALLY AS DANGEROUS
IN THE POSITION OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL AS DONALD TRUMP
IS AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
BARR IS NOT AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE IS DONALD TRUMP'S DEFENSE
ATTORNEY.
HE HAS HIS LACKEY.
>> Greg: LACKEY.
A HEARING ABOUT COMPLAINING
ABOUT GETTING DUMPED AT THE
PROM.
IT'S ABOUT NOT GETTING WHAT THEY
WANTED FROM THE REPORT.
LIKE THEY DIDN'T GET WHAT THEY
WANTED FROM THE ELECTION.
IN RETALIATION, THEY WASTED YOUR
TIME, YOUR MONEY TO THROW PUBLIC
TANTRUM, FULLY EMBRACED BY A
BEDWETTING MEDIA THAT HATES YOU
AND HATE THEMSELVES.
WHO ELSE WOULD CHOOSE TO RELIVE
THEIR FAILURES EVERY DAY BUT A
GROUP OF SELF-LOATHING ZAPS.
THEY RELIVE NOVEMBER 8, 2016,
EVERY DAY JUST TO MAKE A BUCK.
IT'S NOT GROUNDHOG DAY BECAUSE
THAT'S A FUNNY MOVIE.
IT'S THE TITANIC AND THEY ARE
THE BOAT.
GUESS WHO THE ORANGE ICEBERG WA
WAS?
JESSE, I HAVE AN ANALOGY.
>> Jesse: GRANTED.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS LIKE FOR
ME WORKING AT FNC AND NOT CARING
ABOUT THE STORY.
IT'S LIKE BEING AT ESPN AND
BEING FORCED TO COVER THE
HOME RUN DERBY BECAUSE IT'S
MEANINGLESS AND IT'S ALL SHOW.
IT DOESN'T HAVE ANY EFFECT ON
THE OVERALL STANDINGS.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT THIS.
>> Jesse: AND OTHER SPORTS
ANALOGY.
LIKE LOSING A PLAYOFF GAME AND
PRETENDING YOU WON.
THEY LOST SO BADLY YESTERDAY IN
THE MEDIA IS ACTING LIKE THIS
WAS A BIG VICTORY, BUT YOU KNOW
THEY DIDN'T WIN BECAUSE THEY ARE
SO ANGRY AND THEY ARE SO
THREATENED, IF YOU LISTEN TO
THAT.
THE SNOW WILL HAPPEN.
THEY LOST CONTROL OF THE
NARRATIVE AND THEY LOST CONTROL
OF THE PROCESS AS WELL.
IT'S DRIVING THEM CRAZY BECAUSE
THE FULL REPORT IS OUT AND THERE
ARE NO MORE INDICTMENTS.
ESSENTIALLY THE WITCH HUNT IS
OVER BUT THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
MEMO YET.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING TO HEAR
THEM ACCUSE SOMEONE ELSE OF
LYING AFTER TWO YEARS OF LONGING
AND NOT APOLOGIZING.
THEY HAVE LITERALLY NO
SELF-AWARENESS WHATSOEVER BUT
HERE IS WHY BARR IS SO
THREATENING.
BARR OUT LAWYERED MUELLER AND
WEISSMANN ON THE OBSCURE
OBSTRUCTION STATUTE.
THEY DIDN'T CHARGE HIM.
THEY JUST FLOATED THE LEGAL
THEORY THAT WAS TOTALLY UNTESTED
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAD NEVER USED BEFORE.
SO HE BASICALLY ENDED THE COUP.
SECONDLY, THEY ARE NOT USED TO
HAVING SUCH A SEASONED PRO IN
THE DEPARTMENT UNDER
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HAD SESSIONS, DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE THE FIREPOWER TO COMPETE.
THEY HAD ROSENSTEIN WHO WASN'T
REALLY THERE.
HE KIND OF ABDICATED HIS ROLE.
THEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE COME IN,
CLEAN UP SHOP AND THEN REALLY
UNFLAPPABLE EXPLAIN WHAT
HAPPENED WITHIN MUELLER REPORT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN DRIVEN CRAZY
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T COMPETE
RHETORICALLY WITH HIM.
THIRDLY THEY ARE PANICKING
BECAUSE THEY KNOW BARR IS
INVESTIGATING THE INVESTIGATORS.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE FISA
ABUSE.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE HUMAN
INTELLIGENCE ASSETS.
THE UNMASKING COME OF THE
CRIMINAL LEAKS.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT THIS WOULD
BOOMERANG ON THEM AND IT HAS.
THEY ARE REALLY NERVOUS.
>> Greg: DANA, THINK ABOUT
THIS ENERGY.
IT COULD BE SPENT ON GETTING
ELECTED, GETTING A NEW PRESIDENT
MAY BE OR MAY BE CONCENTRATING
ON THE IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
MATTER TO ALL AMERICANS, LIKE
MYSELF.
>> Dana: KARL ROVE WROTE IN
HIS COLUMN SAYING WILL THE
DEMOCRATS BE ABLE TO RESIST
IMPEACHMENT?
THEY HAVE KIND OF ALREADY
STARTED.
DEMOCRATS POLLING AT 70% THAT
THEY WANT IMPEACHMENT BUT WHO
DOESN'T WANT IMPEACHMENT ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OR MOST OF THE
CANDIDATES.
THERE IS NOW 20 ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
THEY'RE ALL GOING TO HAVE TO
COMPETE FOR ATTENTION AGAINST AN
IMPEACHMENT PUSH.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDENT        S
TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDENT        U
TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDENT        E
TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDENT        T
TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDENT        L
TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDENT        A
TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDENT        N
DEBT FREE PLAN OR YOUR CLIMATE
CHANGE PLAN OR WHATEVER ELSE.
THE HEADLINES WILL BE ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
I THINK WHAT'S FRUSTRATING TO ME
IS THEY SEEM TO BE ASKING BARR
TO MAKE A DECISION THAT MUELLER
WASN'T WILLING TO MAKE HIMSELF.
WHY AM A WORLD WITH A THINK THAT
WOULD BE POSSIBLE?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THE LAST THING, I CAN'T STAND
RESIGN POLITICS.
YOU RESIGN.
NO ONE IS RESIGNING OVER ANY OF
THIS, NOBODY.
THERE IS AN ELECTION TO BE HELD.
>> Greg: SPOTLIGHT POLITICS.
YOU GET ON TV WHEN YOU SAY
RESIGN.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
>> Dana: I HAVE NEVER CALLED
ON ANYONE TO RESIGN I DON'T
BELIEVE.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU MAY HAVE
CALLED ON ME TO RESIGN.
>> Dana: NO, NO.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU WERE SAYING
HOW UPSET YOU WERE THAT THE EMMA
KRATZ WERE KAVANAUGHING BARR.
YOU SAID YESTERDAY, YOU DIDN'T
WATCH.
I THINK THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE
WHO DIDN'T READ, APPARENTLY,
INCLUDING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO SAID HE DIDN'T REALLY LOOK
AT THE EVIDENCE BEFORE HE
DECIDED THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTIO
OBSTRUCTION.
HERE'S A GUY WHO SAID I DIDN'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT MUELLER
HAVING ANY OBJECTIONS.
TWO WEEKS AFTER MUELLER SENT HIM
A LETTER SAYING I OBJECTED AND
THIS IS NOT THE FULL STORY THAT
YOU PUT OUT AND IT LEADS TO A
LACK OF PUBLIC'S TRUST.
THEN YOU SAY IT'S THE DEMOCRATS
HAVING A TANTRUM.
LET ME SAY I DIDN'T HEAR THIS
WHEN CONGRESS WAS HAVING
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON BENGHAZI
FOR THE 15TH TIME.
NO, CONGRESS WAS FULFILLING ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE WHICH IS TO
ACT AS AN EQUAL PARTNER UNDER
THE CONSTITUTION TO THE
EXECUTIVE AND TO EMPLOY ITS
RESOURCES, SUBPOENAS AND THE
LIKE, TO GET ANSWERS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S A HOUSE OF THE PEOPLE.
NOW DONALD TRUMP IS FIGHTING
EVERY SUBPOENA.
OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T HAVE A DATE
FOR ROBERT MUELLER TO TESTIFY.
WE DON'T KNOW IF DONALD McGAHN
CAN TESTIFY.
IS SOMETHING BEING HIDDEN?
WHEN KAMALA HARRIS SAYS TO THIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHAT IS
GOING ON?
WERE YOU INFORMED BY ROBERT
MUELLER WESTERNER WELL, I DON'T
KNOW.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
HOW ABOUT THIS.
DO YOU HAVE A RECORD OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH ROBERT
MUELLER?
>> YEAH.
I WAS TAKING NOTES.
CAN WE HAVE THEM?
NO.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Greg: JED, RESPOND TO
JUAN'S OUTRAGE.
>> Jedediah: DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
DECIDE WITH THEY TRUST MUELLER
OR NOT.
WAIT FOR THE REPORT.
NOW IT'S OH, WE DON'T TRUST
MUELLER SO WE NEED BARR TO HAVE
REVIEWED EVERY OUNCE OF
EVIDENCE.
THAT'S WHAT MUELLER WAS THERE
FOR.
NOW EVERYONE IS COMPLAINING WE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE TIMING
OF HOW MUCH WAS RELEASED BY BARR
AND WHEN.
THE WHOLE REPORT IS OUT.
YOU DON'T LIKE BARR?
FINE.
DON'T LIKE TRUMP, FINE.
THERE WERE STILL NO CONSPIRACY
WITH THE RUSSIANS STILL NO
CRIME, STILL NO LEGITIMATE CASE
TO BRING UP AN OBSTRUCTION
CHARGE.
THAT'S THE REALITY.
INSTEAD OF WORRYING ABOUT WHO
DID WATER WHO READ WILD, THIS IS
THE REPORT.
IF WE WERE OF THE SAME MIND, WE
WOULD HAVE MOVED ON.
>> Juan: THAT'S THE MESSAGE
I'M GETTING.
YOU SAY IT'S OVER.
LET'S MOVE ON.
IT'S NOT OVER.
>> Jedediah: THERE IS NO
COLLUSION.
THIS WAS INITIAL STORY ABOUT --
>> Juan: LET'S REITERATE, IT'S
NOT COLLUSION.
IT'S CONSPIRACY.
[ALL SPEAKING]